foreign
hello and welcome to simply learn
webinar
ai or data science mapping your career
path
with ronald van loon the ceo of
intelligent world
advisory board member at simply learn in
data science
i'm secret creek i'm a marketing manager
here at simplylearn and we help you
have an enjoyable webinar today and find
it very useful
a few notes about how to operate webex
controls
when you um which they have asked a
question
use the question mark button enter your
question in the box
hit send and we will keep track of those
questions for the q a at the
end of the webinar and
you can send messages to the panelists
uh by using the chat button selecting
all panelists
again remember to hit send and we'll
keep track of those as well
we're also going to do some interaction
in the form of
polls and we'll start with one simple
one
it has two questions
at this poll
asks what's your current job role
and how are you feeling today and we'll
keep it open for just a minute
so let us know what current job role you
have
also give us a thumbs up or thumbs down
reading on how you feel today
and we'll give you about 20 more seconds
to answer the poll
all right
if you have your last opportunity to
enter your answers
remember to hit submit
and ten
and five four three
two one
you can see that
all results are here
yeah it's good to see
that most of you are feeling well today
so let's go on and i will introduce
ronald rob van loon is the ceo
of intelligent world
he's one of the foremost thought leaders
in data science digital transformation
and he was named by analytica as the
world's number one influencer in data
and analytics
automation and the future of the economy
in tech
he's authored for leading big data and
data science sites including data clone
data science central and he's an
advisory board member here
at sickly learn very pleased to have him
today
and welcome ronald thank you thank you
for having me
so um we'll start with a
question why is there often confusion
surrounding where to start
when it comes to approaching career ai
or data science
thanks uh thanks for the question
stewart and once again thanks for having
me but also
thank you to the audience for for
joining us today
i think today's topic is quite an
interesting one because
although many aspiring industry
professionals they ask this question
but there's actually very little
available very information available to
help them to best use and
direct your career path so if you need
to choose between
ai or between data science if
you look to some analyst firms like
gardner for example they say that 80
of the emerging technologies are going
to have an ai foundation
by 2021 and that's already just in a
couple of months
another endless firm idc they say 75
of the commercial apps they will be
using ai in 2021
so that's ai if we look to data science
it's
i think an incredibly resilient career
if you choose that direction and in fact
even
throughout the hardship of the pandemic
45 of the businesses are still
prioritizing
data analytics as a key priority and
this is according
to the international institute of
analytics so despite this whole
widespread job disruption the pandemic
has brought us there's still been
some intense competition for talent in
this domain which is good for everybody
in in our webinar many students i see
but also many
people from different different roles
different backgrounds
uh different experience probably as well
so i think if you either start
either way in general you can't go wrong
but the confusion what we see is arise
is because there's a lot of
overlap between ai and between data
science and there's conflicting
perspectives on how to start
and when it comes to approaching your
educational path and
ultimately probably even your career
path and further
often we see an overlapping educational
courses for
for two different um subjects as well
so ai is a broad
area that has numerous type of subsets
you can think about machine learning
deep learning computer vision robotics
ar
and vr so all these technologies they
all revolve around
data and they have um massive they need
massive
quantities of data in order to
facilitate
the analysis processes and build your
models and develop your algorithms for
example
so ai technologies they need data
scientists in order to transform the
data into useful
purpose driven business growth because
in the end you want to have results but
also
turn it into operational efficiency or
better decision making or
propel research forward in areas like
biomedicine
or even aerospace so data science
utilize
ai technologies to interpret it and to
analyze this data but also to discover
the patterns and to to make predictions
and to generate the insight and the
technologies depend on
data science practices for for data prep
but also
training machine learning algorithms and
systems so let's
use the same machine learning example
for a moment
so with data prep for machine learning
models
data has to be collected then the
condition of the data has to be
evaluated
and xmind for for your trends
inconsistent or missing information
so the model outputs aren't skewed and
then
the data must be formatted for
consistency that the data can be
accurately aggregated
and after that the data quality has to
be enhanced by filling in the missing
values before you perform your feature
engineering
to ensure that your algorithms have good
representation of the data so
and then you you then the data has to be
curated
for the training from the machine
learning algorithms
so many careers actually require
extensive data scientist skills
and as touch on in the beginning there
are many career opportunities
in both fields so data scientist related
jobs are experiencing
a substantial growth 37 percent um
more growth in demand for these type of
jobs and they have been
on the top of linkedin emerging job
lists already now for three years
so for now you can't go wrong with any
any choice
and a lot of this growth gets used to
the evolving state of
careers like statistician or the
emergence of new
data demands in in areas like high level
research for example
so hiring for data engineer has also
jumped and almost 35 percent in the last
five years which is substantial and
mostly because of the need
to build and to manage infrastructures
to handle this technology adoption
if we look to ai specialists chris
they're booming as well and
the annual hiring rates have increased
by even 74 percent of the last
four years actually that we have for
example cyber security specialist rules
that have been quickly growing this year
and linkedin has reported that demand
these
these skills that have risen by around
30
on annual basis i think an interesting
note as well on this career is that
the security careers that there's many
openings in government positions as well
for example in the us in washington dc
um
but there's just these are just a few
examples and and
to be frankly there's so many statistics
for careers and
in ai and in data science it
demonstrates growth
in hiring rates and in demand and
finally i think
there has been a change in demand for
specific skill set due to the current
circumstances due to the pandemic
and the course pending corresponding
increase in technology adoption
across pretty much every industry that
we see the
see the last couple of months so
hopefully
stuart just gives a little bit of an
overview and clarifies the confusion
that can you do me a favor uh ronald
we're having a question about
what people can see your powerpoint
would you
reshare it please yeah i will
um let me know
once you can see it again
give me a moment let me uh take over the
presentation
and then re-share your ability hold on
okay now you should be able to share
your uh powerpoint again
okay let me try
can you see my screen
and i would say it on my ad but
unfortunately webex was not broadcast
um so let's move on then
uh first off if you go back one slide so
that people can see what the content was
and we talked about the interactions and
overlaps between
ai and data science
and now let's go ahead
so what are the main differences between
ai and data
science yeah so
maybe give a quick generalizations if we
look to
ai has very high levels of scientific
processing
versus data science which relies more on
the statistical
and the mathematical techniques we first
start looking deeper into the data
science part so a driver for
many revolutionary advances in in almost
every industry
is the integral to our own modern
concept of being data driven every
company wants to achieve this
which is necessary basically i think for
almost every business today and
especially now in this pandemic
so without data science there for
example wouldn't be
the recommendation engines which are
when you're shopping on amazon
or for example the personalized menus
that you are scrolling
if you're watching netflix there's also
no strava fitness i don't know if
everybody knows it it's an app
for when you're doing fitness where they
have a social network where they help
cities to support their athletes um also
another
type of example is wattpad which is
providing a hosting platform for over 4
million
self-published authors and more than 80
million readers
they don't have these recommendations if
you don't have data science and
although this i think particular
examples and
one the one is the wet pad has been
featured in in some of the major online
publications recently
um another example is uh which i had the
pleasure a couple of weeks ago to hear
firsthand information about
how they're advancing the weather
prediction
industry where data science is really
crucial so they're using data from
a ton of different sources and you can
think about
sensors sensors that they even put on
cars to better predict
the weather conditions and help
businesses and other
entities to improve the safety and avoid
problems
that come from bad weather conditions
storms floods etc
so data science i think is a
multi-disciplinary field
that derives insights from the data
to help them to improve their
decision-making um
and to drive digital transformation into
initiatives within organizations but
also
to overcome very specific challenges
that organizations have that can be
solved by by data so
on on a technical level i think it's
statistically driven
and data science involves pre-processing
it involves analysis
but also you have to think about pattern
identification or visualization and
prediction
and it's the ability to understand all
these data trends
and understand all the patterns so for
example data scientists in financial
services can analyze data to help
companies to optimize their financial
products and their financial services to
improve the customer experience but also
to perform
risk analysis
let me share also an example for for ai
um i had recently an interesting
discussion with
a top technology provider which was in
the healthcare space
and they were telling me how important
data analytics were not only for
creating new levels of efficiency and
innovation in areas for example like
diagnostics where you can imagine it but
also for ensuring that doctors can
simply
focus on the patient care so augment a
doctor
so say you are a healthcare provider
like a hospital and you're dealing with
a lot of medical equipment and a lot of
medical technology
so all this generates tons of data and
this data can be really
challenging to manage and to turn into
insights for fast diagnostics and
decision making
and especially if you are on the
intensive care
or emergency departments where it's a
matter of life and death
so ai technologies they help them to
turn into this huge amount into
transformational solutions into the
space like ruling out
any number of potential issues for
example and helping to quickly figure
out
what the root cause is of a patient's
medical issue when
there's numerous possibilities as what
the issue could be and especially in
emergency situations
this is really crucial and it can help
the diagnosis for for the doctors so ai
is about
understanding and it's about
interpreting data
and using predictive models to forecast
these type of
future events it enables also machines
to make
connections between different data
components and it brings
automation to all different of of
business processes for better cost
cost efficient work rpa is a good
example which is evolving right now with
the help of
um with the help of ai in other ways
it's used to help
people to perform their jobs better i'm
taking over these tasks that aren't
valuable for us this typical mundane
task
and the people can work and focus more
on
one and the complex work but also on a
more the creative type of work
and ai uses computer algorithms and
principles from
computational algorithms and software
engineering for example
it's creating a machine learning and
natural language and natural language
processing
algorithms for more context aware type
of advertising
so yeah hopefully this makes it
the difference between ai and data
science more clear but i think
in the coming questions we will dive
even more into this
this subject thank you
um so which industries and types of
companies are hiring data science and ai
professionals
yeah i think i can have a list of 50 or
100 industries i think every industry
that has some kind of data uses
data analytics and can hire data science
and ai professionals but
i think i can select a couple of them to
go a little bit more in depth
so for example take manufacturing and
imagine spending hundreds of hours
manually going over
video footage of a pipe system
or of a propeller on a commercial
airline or
controlling electrical wires along a
power line
and that's something that you don't want
to do manually because
of data science and ai this can be
automated
so that the human works don't have to
spend all the time
checking these these type of hazardous
type of
time consuming activities but they're
also very error prone if
if people are doing that if you can do
this with computer vision
and image recognition you can be very
accurate and fast
in the manufacturing industry data
scientists they implement for example
rpa robot process automation solutions
that improve
building and assembly in factories
across
over the world and also automate
legacy systems with rpa or
manufacturing analytics are used to
improve the processes
and the operations by analyzing data
from
from your factory and from your
manufacturing plants and your logistical
operations so
different areas within the manufacturing
domain
are specific and specific to to
um to explore but also we have of course
the general
departments which is applicable for
every industry whether it's sales and
marketing whether it's its finance for
example
um let's discuss another industry for
example finance
so ai enabled automation can potentially
save banks in the u.s more than
70 billion by 2025
so that's according to to business
insider but
this type of amount this really
indicates the value of ai and of data
science
so in finance everything from fraud
detection
or you can think about financial
analysis or improving
investment strategies or debt collection
or even regulatory compliance
these are areas that data scientists are
are needed
then if we talk and i expect many of
them
are in this this webcast it's the genics
and the millennials they are becoming
the biggest
customers for financial institutions and
budgets are searching to support the r d
for this
new digital solutions to make it appeal
to this group
so also in sales and marketing there's a
lot of room
and there's also room for evolution here
through
ai through machine and through deep
learning
and demand for professionals with the
right skill sets to develop these
creative mobile banking services that's
just one of the available
opportunities which you you have in in
the financial industry
another area i would like to touch is
for example e-commerce
you can imagine everybody knows the
large e-commerce companies who use
a lot of ai technologies but you can
also think for example about
pokemon go and they use ar ar
technology to superimpose virtual images
into
the real environment so the augmented
reality technology
is driven by ai as well
also retails and e-commerce companies
whether you think about burberry or
maybe nike or sephora they use
augmented reality and virtual reality
technologies to help the customers
to shop more in an immersive
and personal way so the customers that
use these technologies to to virtually
try on makeup for example or you can
sit in your room and how your furniture
looks like in your home before you even
make make a purchase
last week i saw even where you can
buy a truck and you sit in the truck
you walk through the truck and you do
virtual truck
buying or virtual car buying uh which is
new technologies that are there now
to support digital sales even of the
the biggest let's say assets that that
you never imagined you can
sell vertically as well so there's a lot
of areas in this space for ai for
machine learning specialists
and also for data scientists to drive
this new innovation and
and honest existing technology solutions
so it's
also common for data scientists to
improve the customer personalization
and implement for example chatbots that
act as as customer support agents
and improve marketing and advertising
strategies that target his unique
customer and business needs
next to this one um i think there's one
one more industry which i would like to
discuss and i discussed already before
is the health deck so
healthcare is a valuable field for data
scientists because the doctors can work
much more effectively
and the patients the patients they can
be treated
with much more accuracy and everybody
can imagine
that's very valuable and especially as
the healthcare costs
they they go sky high in every company
in every country
so um also if you look in healthcare
improving treatment plans by analyzing
patient data is very common
as well for example as as drug discovery
what you have now with code 19
drugs that are developed ai and
data science are play an important role
but also for example with pregnancy
management
so in precision medicine for example
patients can benefit from
really personalized and individualized
approaches to treatment
based upon their own medical and their
genetic history or even their lifestyle
and their environmental
conditions rather than using this this
one's
size fits all type of of medicines
so what what we see is that traditional
higher education can use technologies
like
ai and help them rejuvenate this
industry
in in all different kinds of valuable
ways
um yeah so i think if we also look to
some additional research conducted by
microsoft and by idc recently
they say that 92 percent of of the
people served in the higher ed
education institutions they're already
trying to use ai to create this
competitive new solutions
and better personalized education for
for the students so there's a lot of
potential areas
for ai and for data science
and over in let's say as well to for
example in education
um or more in the communication to drive
more inclusivity
or equalizing in education
and to create more in-depth
type of experimental learning scenarios
and that's i think very important now
and with the the covet 19 situation so
there are more let's say industries but
i think this this
is a couple of industries which are
definitely high
um high on the list
yeah as you said
currently spanning nearly every industry
so what are some of the most popular and
in demand
types of careers in each of these two
fields
yeah as well here next to the different
type of industries
there's quite some different careers
that you can choose
which makes it great but on the other
hand maybe it makes the choice
more difficult but i would like to take
a couple of
important at least um most the
the roles that are most in demand and go
through these and
yeah maybe if you have more questions um
you can can ask afterwards but there are
so many different roles
in this domain where you can define your
career so
let's start for example with a data
scientist
i think if you look to a data scientist
they are there to
to solve certain problems they're also
some kind of
sometimes called the wizards of data and
they have to extract
meaning from the data and interpret it
to help the companies to develop
sometimes new products or help them to
develop new services
but also can help them with overcoming
operational challenges or or make
certain
objective decisions really based on data
so they do a lot of different things
depending on the industry
and depending on the the company where
they're working so it's not
that if you're data scientist you have a
fixed items
and a list of items that you have to do
so some examples are creating customized
data products so an organization can
better understand the customers
or you can think about developing
extensive online experimental frameworks
for product development or
or streamlining your productization of
your machine and model so there's
a series of activities and then the data
scientist is rather broad in supporting
organizations
another role for example is a bi
developer
a bi developer uses different software
tools to help
turn data into insights that can help
with the decision making process that's
the the general let's say a role in the
description and they also
might do everything from coding and
testing and to helping to implement
the new type of tools into the business
process new type of analytics tools
but they're also responsible for
translating business requirements into
more technical requirements so they're
the bridge between
business and and i.t and they help with
data warehouse designing or they help
with
bi software development an example
um i think it would be like researching
and planning out
new type of solutions to address this a
new
different type of business problem if
you start with analytics start with a
business problem
and then you can like introducing new
data visualization software so that all
the users across the company
can have access to the data when they
need it where they need it and they can
understand the data so really
democratizing the data
another role i think which is important
is a business analyst
and they go between it
and businesses as well and they use data
analytics to evaluate processes but also
to figure out requirements and
communicate
all different kind of data-driven
solutions to the business leader so they
need to have very good communication
skills and translation skills of
translating um let's say i t in into
understandable stories and they are the
drivers of of change because of this
they they introduce and they help and to
manage
um these changes of the products but
also the new software the hardware and
the processes
to add value to your business so they
really need to understand
the business and translate it into into
solutions
so for example they look at their
company's historical and their current
data and then decide
what can be brought into the company to
make this
ex the existing solutions work more
efficiently so
it's really about improving every step
in in the business
another important role i think is the
data architects
um i call them sometimes the the puppet
masters of data
they evaluate business data sources and
they develop
a plan to to integrate but also
centralize and to maintain all the the
different data sources
and maintaining data sources you can
imagine now
is becoming a big big challenge for
organizations as they have so many
different sources so many different
data types and so this is an important
role for organizations to
have a solid foundation and to further
grow and in a way to make
that they also help in in a way to make
sense out of this
sometimes data and data landscape that
the organizations have you probably all
have heard of the data silos where
organizations are struggling with and
every organization has
um unless they maybe are a quite young
company and could build everything
on one platform so they
are often called upon to develop the
roadmap
for your data management and as i said
this is becoming more important
for organizations to have a long lasting
foundation
so this requires the knowledge of data
modeling but also
database management also data
warehousing
and then to give an example a data data
architect
would be would be deployed to visualize
how an adjustment in in data acquisition
would ultimately benefit the company
and the use of data and then create a
framework to guide
all the different data activities
um one one rule i think
ai we were discussing today data science
and ai so is an ai
architect i think it's even one of the
hottest jobs
at the moment their salaries often go
over one hundred thousand
us dollars um annually um
so this is is um yeah one if you can
get such a role um you're in a very good
position
so you can use ai technology frameworks
as an ai architect to develop and to
maintain
an organizational architecture and you
can
adapt it over time as businesses need to
change
organizations really need this right now
on one of the needs a data management
architecture and as a next step they
need to have an ai
architecture which is part of the data
management architecture by the way
so this requires intensive knowledge of
of ai
applications but also all different
kinds of tools and technologies and
programming language like
like python and to give an example
a business might hire an ai architect to
develop
a cohesive connectivity solution across
various iot type of sensors
move it to the cloud and and use a
machine learning solution for this um
amazon
everybody knows them it's one of the
biggest companies hiring in in this
domain especially for
aws related type of functions
um one one last
rule i would like to address is robotics
engineers
they work on physical bots like machine
arms in industrial manufacturing or they
can work on
on drones for product delivery for
e-commerce or all different kind of kind
of applications as you can
imagine with drones or they can work on
on virtualbox and you can think about
conversational ai solutions
also called in intelligent chatbots and
different kinds of names
more or less for the same which are
often used in
in customer service and there's quite
some developments to go
to make them really human friendly
and this is a huge growing field uh
conversational ai
which will expand and change the world i
think
i think substantially as you get voice
conversations
with bots which are going to a human
human level
so a professional in this area may
devote your expertise to either
a hardware or or a software focused role
you have
two choices typical someone in this
field develops prototypes or creates
and tests all different kinds of
machines and
he or she can manage the software that
supports the machines
but they also can for example research
the best ways to manufacture
robotic systems and and the funny thing
is there are quite some
technology providers now coming on the
market where you can have
for 50 60 a device where you can build
robots
with which which is a great way
to start and to kick off and to start
trying this so
that's always something to do and
educate yourself
next to to your job and see it as some
kind of hobby but there's
i think many other type of
roles um but due to the time i think we
are a little bit limited but you have
the computer vision engineer you have
the machine learning engineer full stack
engineer
a cloud engineer so there's multiple
different roles
that can be addressed and how you can
define your career path
so i covered a bunch of rules uh stuart
but
maybe yeah the other ones we do for
another
another
webcast good idea
good idea we can go ahead and do
another poll this one asks
are attendees
what roles do they or
skills do they currently use in their
jobs
roles with skills in data science and ai
machine learning and
we listed just a few representative
skills of course it's not comprehensive
just go ahead and
answer the poll we'll keep it open just
for about a minute or so
and then we'll get back to um
presentation but
are you mostly involved in
analytics big data business analytics
ai and machine learning or do you use
other
data science and iml skills in your work
today
again this is what you're currently
using
what does your current job or role
required to require you to use and what
do you feel comfortable using today
and uh we'll
close the poll in 20 seconds
so if you get your answers in and hit
submit
within the next 10 seconds or so
and
the largest number of respondents say
data analytics
the second largest they ai and machine
learning
so the people who are
practitioners in the field already but i
think we help a lot of people who are
curious about it and are not yet using
these skills
which is good to know because that's
that's why we are here to help them in
the career path uh-huh
so let's go on to the next question
and you talk about career paths we talk
about
learning paths and educational paths
they help people get
to the career they want and
so are there basic building blocks
basic fundamental learning and powers
that
help people establish a foundation if
they're uncertain
where they want to go between data data
science and ai
yeah i think the good point is there is
quite some overlap
so um you can have a foundation and and
you can
go in in different directions afterwards
with this foundation
um which which is helpful so both ai and
data science they have
similar type of knowledge foundations
you can think about mathematics
but also statistics and programming
skills for example
so it's important to understand that
data science career paths typically
require
knowledge in math but also
for example like statistics or or
probability or calculus and
algorithm if we look to to
machine learning algorithms alongside
performing analysis and discovering
insights
from data they require math math is the
core
educational pillar for for a data
scientist and regardless of your future
or your industry or your career path
math is is
required so it ensures that you can help
an organization
solve problems and innovate more quickly
but also optimize model performance for
example
or effectively apply complex data
towards business type of challenges so
these
areas they are essential educational
core
for for anyone interested in in the in
the field
and i think it's a good idea to get
initial exposure to
to data science focused areas of
education when you're in the process of
deciding
if data science is the best fit for you
so
you can't go wrong focus on mathematics
on statistics and
programming so next to exploring
different machine learning courses and
and branch outs
branch out a little bit from there so if
this machine learning courses interested
you
explore ai related courses for example
like
coding or data modeling or data mining
or different kind of programming
language but also
algorithms and visualization so all
data scientists they need an
understanding of coding and programming
languages
and then you can think about the main
ones python
java but also r of course and you also
need
a deep understanding about how to think
about and apply
algorithms it's i think an obvious
obvious skill as well and then learning
how to communicate and this is something
that um not always everybody
thinks about how to communicate how how
the model will be used and the results
of that model
and how they're going to aid to the
decision making process
process so these skills need to be
developed as well which is not um yeah
it's a soft skill
where what many data scientists often
don't focus on and that can
let's say delay their career model
development
that's another important part of the
education path because you need to
understand
how to adjust models and parameters
according to
get the desired get the desired outcome
for those maybe who are interested in
analytics and
in business shape your skills in data
mining
data wrangling and data modeling and
database management
but also for this part programming
languages like python there are
as i just mentioned but also you can
think about
sus or c and c c plus plus
to take courses in data management
which involves many facets of managing
data such as
cleansing validation but also storing
integration
processing so you can unlock the full
potential of
of what your data has to offer to your
organization you really understand this
this involves building strategies to
bring
value to your data and explain the
strategies communicate the strategies
to your to you to your superiors as well
another thing is to ensure your
developing skills to to understand
multiple analytical functions and and
work with
unstructured data from various sources
structured unstructured data
there are many different type of data
just try them out and find out
where your skills are and what we see as
well data analysts
can normally do all kinds of basic
descriptive statistics
and they can visualize the data so
in this case of course in data wrangling
becomes essential for for data analysts
because it's it's in the process of
cleaning and
unifying your data so that it can be
accessed and used
for your analysis processes so i i
realize
it's it's a lot um and it's it's it's a
lot of time and a lot of
let's say education that that's required
but
take your steps and and define your
steps in these
areas so you have the right foundation
either whether you move more into data
science or move more
into into ai so stewart hopefully that's
that's helpful yes it is
um when
people have this foundation and are
looking ahead
how do you advise them to to create a
career roadmap
and choose the best path to take
especially when it comes to choosing
further training
i think it's the essence of today it's a
great question
important for everybody i think in in
the audience but not
such an easy question as everybody has
its own background design ideas
it's its own hobbies and so
if you are unsure of your career path
and that that you want to take
i think what's what can work very well
is to work backwards
so looking at a certain corresponding
skill sets required
under each path so decide on the career
choice
that meets best your the skills that
you're ideally suited for
and you are interested in developing and
work backwards so
do you want to be to become a machine
learning engineer or data scientist
or business intelligence developers or
a data analyst or maybe data architect
to to just
name a few and we listed a couple of
more before
there are many different career paths in
your data science and ai journey so you
have to
find it out but if you work backwards at
least you have a certain direction and
you know where to go and you can find
out if you really like it
and along your path feel free to
to take where the flow brings you and
the flow brings you because the
developments are going
very quickly in this domain um so it's
it's not always
easy to predict which direction you you
are
going in the next five to ten years as
this whole domain is changing
quite quickly so check out which jobs
are most interesting for you
or meet your particular skills and your
capabilities
and also of course the skills you like
and the skills you're interested in and
the skills you you want to develop so
really
follow your heart and and what you
really love and where you spend
your time as well next to your job and
that's the area where you want to
develop because then it doesn't feel
like a job
and um yeah if your job becomes your
your passion
um i think you're in there in the right
in the right direction
so look at the requirements that job
positions offer as well
um and in the particular field that
you're interested in
so study these type of job functions
what type of qualifications are needed
in the hired field so you can think
about sites like
glassdoor or sites i think like indeed
and examine the job posting what type of
candidates and skills
and experience these title businesses
really want and really ask so you are
sure
that you are up to date with the skills
that you are developing that they match
what is required in in the market
you can also learn about different areas
of your study depending on
on the career goals so learn about the
qualifications that businesses are
looking for
in the prospective hires how much
education
do they need or do they require and
is it a bachelor degree or maybe even a
master's degree or even a phd um that's
important to define your strategy as
well
are these specific requirements from
that organization
that they might might need from you
and so if you really want to apply for
it can you can you
match these type of requirements is
there specific knowledge of
particular fields or industry that you
would be necessary
to to get your job that you want and
talking about industry
if you have specific industry knowledge
and you have
no background in math or no background
in data science
you have a good position because if you
have industry knowledge
that's what organizations are looking
for if you can
support it by initial and analytic
skills and data science skills
and industry knowledge is is very
important so
if you move at a certain moment into a
certain industry
that's where you can further grow and
that's what organizations are looking
for the combination of these skills plus
the industry knowledge
think about other skills cultivate your
your communication skills i mentioned
already
before but it's important don't forget
it um storytelling capabilities
if you can explain it in three to five
minutes what you're doing
um that's what organizations like
because they
think if you can explain it in five
minutes and you can communicate it to
your to your superiors or even to the
board level
that's what they would like because they
don't often
understand in detail what you are doing
so communication is
is crucial in this also
in in an industry have some business
equipment
think about the typical problems that
are solved look at competitors what type
of problems do they solve
with the help of data science or ai
what's what are the prioritization
um companies really looking continuously
at each other what is the other
competitor doing
and do we need to do the same so if you
analyze this for them and come up with
ideas
you're one step ahead
think about collaboration type of skill
sets that you need it's it's not
something although you maybe work now
from home it's not that you can
do your job on your own it's always a
team sport right now
a team sport with different roles
different departments
and different skill sets within the data
science teams as
as well and stay on top of
emerging technology trends the
technology is evolving so
fast and that some jobs maybe that you
do today
can be automated tomorrow and so you
need to keep
developing your skill sets and really
watch
closely to the market and which skill
sets
are replaced by ai now maybe the coming
year the coming next years because
that's how you can
let's say prevent that you learning
yourself skill
that will be automated in the near
future
um this communication and storytelling
skills they're they're
often overlooked i think by data
scientists
and i can't stress it enough there but
they are essentially
very important skill to to develop so
not everyone
who works in an organization is going to
be a data scientist or understand
data science the same way that you do so
being able
to explain your skill and how you are
working
is really important for other people to
understand
and in a simple way what you are doing
and one important part is
is here as well is they have high
expectations
if you start the expectations are
tremendous
they don't understand what is required
to get the results and that
the chance to get results is is
sometimes
even very small so you need to explain
them
what you do what are the chances for
failure
because otherwise they think you don't
do your job well and maybe you do your
job
job perfectly but either the
infrastructure there the skills are not
there the data is not there the data
quality is not there so there's all kind
of requirements
um based upon which your project
cannot work out at this moment maybe in
the future or the data sets are not not
right or not complete
so this is great for communication with
with
people on the business side but also
with different stakeholders
and people across the departments so
that they can
understand how you are bringing value to
them
um with the help of data and with
the work you're you're working on right
now and how that will impact
them and how that will impact their work
as well
and how it often can augment their work
so that's important
to to communicate to to your
organizations
um also last point i think be sure to
to follow some some companies that
you're interested in
working for on social media so they
provide maybe some information as
potential job openings but also areas of
development
new type of developments they they're
investing in new areas
look at their labs what type of areas
they're investing in because that's the
foundation for further rollout
and new type of careers that they are
often often looking for
so there's quite some some choices as to
what but
i think some initial tips to to get
started
okay thank you um
so what would be an example
of a specific educational career
or training path rather um for data
science career
versus one for ai
yeah it um i can only give an example
um as there are hundreds of different
paths that you can
can go for so if you look from data
science
let's say you choose your career in data
science and
your ultimate career objective is to
start as a data scientist and maybe
eventually become a data science project
manager in a big tech company
so you're going to to need knowledge and
statistical analysis
as well as knowledge in big data
platforms for example
in hadoop but also you you can take
courses in in data science
in statistics in analytics in computer
science
and also even electrical engineering so
in
you know that so many popular tech
organizations
are using natural language processing
right right now
they use image recognition technologies
so that's something that you can focus
on and
maybe you study hard to learn and to
understand how you can gain
an edge in in the job market already by
preparing this
this type of work because these are the
skills that these companies need and
then you can gain competencies
in coding skills and get some experience
in python in
r and maybe some other programming
languages and
i think it doesn't matter what career
path you choose
so you know as a data scientist you
you're going to need at least some level
of
coding experience so it's always good to
to get this experience
and even if you decide to branch off
maybe even to a business analyst or or
managerial role
it's always a great foundation and then
you want to
maybe refine your skills and
develop your skills in in sql or in
machine learning
techniques can think about
classification or cross-validation
or even maybe neural networks um
then you get some some some
certifications
and you probably want to obtain a higher
education
degree and move to either bachelor or a
master
in statistics or in computer science or
in mathematics
and then you need to to focus on the
ongoing skills and the education so you
always need to
educate yourself and really watch the
market closely from what type of
demand there would be and maybe even
get additional certifications for for
your career
um i think that's um for data science an
example
if we take an example for a career in ai
and yeah it's it's one of the the most
important and impactful job fields
at the current time it's it's one of the
hottest others jobs
so your career objective for example is
becoming machine learning engineer for a
large um
social network company and eventually
maybe
lead a machine learning engineering team
so you can start with the fundamentals
in statistics
with the fundamentals in probability in
data modeling
data visualization data analysis then
you probably
want to narrow your areas of study to
most of your courses in machine learning
in
deep learning or or even develop your
reinforcement learning
skills as well which are can be related
to
yes your statistical skills for each
respective area
of your study after that you you can
move on to courses
in your programming skills that means as
well this is always
the right path um and you can't go wrong
python are maybe c c plus plus
um and combine them with your your
mathematic courses like calculus like
linear algebra and and for example data
modeling
as a next step then you want to gain
competencies
in computer science maybe in in
programming
like a computer architecture or data
structures
and maybe algorithms or software
engineering and
system design so also
um yes some that's a more developed
type of machine learning the supervised
and the unsupervised learning area
where you want to experience more
implementing machine learning models you
can
think about using the logistic register
regression or the k means clustering and
develop these type of skills and with
the certifications in this area
yeah i think you have a solid chance
getting more
visibility and job opportunities and you
can
obtaining higher educations you can go
to your master or your phd
and you could even consider a post
graduate program
with more in-depth knowledge where you
can think about
tensorflow or nlp or or computer vision
for example um yeah so
this is just one example for for each
direction
but i think there are a hundred
different parts and
follow your heart follow your
your passion i think that's important
from both
industry and from from skill set and
based upon this
try to find organizations that need your
skill set that need your skill set
from both the industry um as well as the
the technical skill sets so
for anyone who's looking up um yeah
maybe maybe some
some final thoughts for for anyone who's
looking up their educational path to
either
data science or to a um to ai
i think just remember there's no right
or wrong way and that's
i think the most important important
message so
there's no conclusive area to focus on
first um
you have to think about what you really
like what you're interested in
and not be afraid to explore and to
experiment with different
learning paths and do something
next to your job what you like because
that's that's the area probably that you
really love
and for those who are already in a
professional
and as a professional in a certain area
always keep educating yourself because
the chance is
quite likely that your area will be
automated in in the coming years so you
need to keep developing yourself
and the business and technology
landscape they are changing
um and in the other end i think we are
in the midst of a rapid advancement and
evolutions in our industry
due to this pandemic the tech vendors
they grow
even more rapidly so they invest even
more
in in new advancements and new type of
technologies
so it's a smart move to continuously
strive towards acquiring
new skills and skills that interest you
that further enhance your
existing capabilities but also gain new
ones
to get a better job to get a different
job or
develop the job that you're in right now
if we look to demand
demand for ai demand for data science
it's rising don't worry about that and
for both fields
we have remained fairly immune
to a lot of uncertainties that we have
seen in in the last years
so the demand will be will be there
start with your basic programming start
with statistics start with with
mathematics and try some machine
learning courses out
and then go from there so no matter
which educational path you will start
with first
once you gain your fundamental knowledge
base you are in a great
position to shape your career a correct
project in a way that looks best for you
and that fits your unique unique goals
thank you um we're running
to the end of the presentation
time and i'd like to if you have time
you'd be able to take a couple questions
uh we have so many coming in from
the audience but first i'd like to
to run that last poll give you a chance
to rest your voice
and this last poll
is
basically the same as the previous one
but looking forward what
skills are you and the audience
interested in learning and adding to
your toolkit
um adding to your repertoire
to build your career in data science and
ai and machine learning
and we'll just give this about
another minute um
and there's already a trend i can see
from my end which is
uh ai and machine learning is
by far the most popular choice in the
whole
give you about another 15 seconds to get
your answers in
remember to hit enter
and then
five four three
two one
and yes see ai machine learning
by far the most
popular answer to this poll
not a surprise
so let's move on to the questions as i
said there are so many but we only have
time for a few
i do want to ask um
a question from doris about
how ai and machine learning
uh affect management strategy and
management decisions
um especially how you see
management strategy being integrated
with
business forecasting and predictive
analytics
yeah i think if you look for management
strategy and i think the pandemic
really changed management strategies as
well um
companies now first had to look at their
cash flow
they started the management strategy
once the pandemic started
and have an organizational wide cash
flow inside
that was to get back to to let's say
operation
and from there if they have the cash
flow clear they wanted to have
clear views of their strategy from
insights
from the supply chain because if you
can't deliver your product because there
is a pandemic in the area
from your production and you have a
challenge in selling it
and the third one is what from strategy
perspective is
what can you sell and what's in demand
and you can imagine so last week there
was a
retailer who had the digital channel a
physical channel
and their physical channel four pillars
they had
two were digital and two were physical
and they were fully closed
so you can imagine that your strategy
goes upside down
from one day to the other if one channel
or two channels even are closed from the
four pillars and this
was the last a large um
company in in luxury products
so nowadays strategy is really
defining on what's happening in the
market i think that's that's one part
and
i think the other part for strategy
what's important is
there's two type of companies right now
as i see them companies
who really suffer due to this pandemic
and airlines hotels restaurants
every type of company every type of
company
who is really affected so they really
try to
get their act together save their money
focus on cost saving so
all the strategies they can develop to
save cost
and to save cash and to reorganize their
structure that's where their focus will
be yet
then you have the companies that really
thrive
especially the tech companies i'm not
sure i'm sure that i hear a lot of noise
from a microphone
so i think there are there isn't a
number of companies that really thrive
you can think about the technology
companies and they really look at okay
how to have a solid foundation and these
technology companies have
already found a foundation and the
foundation i mean a data management
platform where they can collect the data
where they can
manage the data and develop new type of
tools and services on top of it
and they really look at new type of
opportunities so how to
further their business
especially from a customer perspective
so how to help customers better faster
with a better customer experience so
they will
define the areas natural language
processing conversational ai
um predictive analytics with predicting
um what what you're going to buy or
where you're going to click at
um so that that's um the
two type of companies and i think
now it's wise to focus on the companies
who really can thrive
they have the money they double down on
investments
from new people from new skills from new
technologies
um and and the other ones yeah they they
have a hard time so they will do
everything
you cut cost if you are in a good
position and know how to cut cost
um then you have a good position with
let's say the
the companies that have a hard time as
well but otherwise focus
on the ones that can really thrive and
can benefit
from the from the pandemic to do more
digital
or are are already fully digital
thanks thank you um we have a question
from somebody who asked whether a high
school level of mathematics is
uh sufficient to get started in data
science or
something additional required um
yeah i think it depends a little bit
from from what your high school
level is for me it's not clear um in all
the different countries
what the level is if i compare it to
european levels
um if you are a star at least
you can learn very quickly so it's for
sure enough to start and to learn in
parallel
but i think if you start developing and
you want to develop your further
self focus more on a bachelor but
to start i think anyhow um if you look
to
all the capabilities that new
technologies are
are offering but also new type of tools
it becomes easier and easier
to um to develop and to model
um yourself where the skill sets
it's important to know but it's not
important
to know everything so i i
always believe in start trying it
yourself
and discover it and if you have the
basic skills
let's say the high school type of skills
and you pick it up quickly
it can move you forward very very
quickly
and at a certain moment you will
discover where you're facing
let's say your restrictions on the other
hand i see
quite some developments where this
restriction restrictions
are solved by better technology that
augments you
in taking and creating each next step so
your skill set becomes let's say
important to understand but less
important to do it because this
part will be automated i hope i i make
it clear what i mean
um but yeah i think yes you can start
but see where where you get where you
find your limitation if you find your
limitation
then continue your education in
mathematics
question from someone in our youtube
live audience
who asks is it possible to work for
amazon online
as a data scientist for ai i think
they're
they're asking if you can work remotely
yeah so i think what's changed and to
give you a little bit of statistics i i
did a webcast last
week with a large telecom
provider cisco they
they had did research and initially
before the pandemic
only five percent worked from home now
89 of the people
they like to have some kind of hybrid
model of working from home
and and working in the office and you
can imagine still there's the pandemic
and most of the people they um yeah they
work from home
but even after this pandemic
which will will come in in a certain
period i'm not going to do a forecast
about this
but um organizations really shifted
their minds
in working on distance so i think
from the coming months the coming years
it will not go back to the old situation
anymore
and it will be much easier to work on
distance
then it's the question okay um
can you do this for amazon or or not um
on one hand what i see in general is
that large technology companies they are
much more flexible compared to
traditional companies for people to work
from home
so they even say and if you look to
companies like
microsoft facebook google some say okay
till january
you cannot come into the office some say
till june or july you can't
come into the office or you're free to
do so
so these companies stimulate working
from home
and then what you see already is the
realization
okay does this person need to be in the
u.s
does he need to be in san francisco at
the highest square meter price
uh which is is probably there in the
whole of us or maybe even
um from the square meter price globally
or can you work
on a very large distance and only go
once half a year or a certain period to
um to your team and meet meet physically
so i think the opportunities from
working on distance
are going to substantially increase the
coming months and the coming years
what about learning long distance we
have a guest from liberia
who asks what are the opportunities to
learn data science in a country that
doesn't have
much of that teaching infrastructure
um what would the uh the options be for
somebody
to pursue that
education and training yeah i think that
the location
doesn't matter so much anymore what's
what doesn't matter
is your your drive um you need to have
proper internet access
and you need to be willing to develop
your skills and you need to contact
organizations
where you can develop where you can
develop your skills that offer the
opportunities to develop your skills so
one ntf
let's say the education you do the
formal edit type of education and you
have the education you do
at organizations um on the other hand
what you still will see is
if you if you can learn from other
people in a physical setting
that's also very helpful um but
as a data science data scientist you can
work remotely you can learn from others
while not being in in the same room so
i don't think it's hindering you that
you're in a different location
um i can imagine that
let's say companies sometimes have
preferences
from people in certain regions that are
well known
for um high quality data scientists
and and yeah india of course is a
great area known for um
well-educated data scientist and that
for some countries
you're not on uh seen as an area that is
very well developed
but there i think in the end it depends
on your own drive
on your own capability to communicate
with these these countries to show that
you
you are the best and to be very
proactive
in your communication in approaching
them
and as long as you have the skills um
and they want you
yeah you will get there just a couple
more questions
one uh is if you could
comment on the definition of big data
and how it differs from data analytics
yeah so if you look to big data um and
data analytics so big data is all the
data collection the data engineering the
data
processing the machine learning
algorithms
and if you look to data analytics it's
providing the insights
in this data visualize this insight
and take actions or make it possible to
take actions
um on this insights which is more than
the analytics part and the insights part
so one is more the the whole data
pipeline and the other one
is more how to convert the data into
valuable insights
and uh and and help the people
um in the organization that they can
take either decision themselves or they
can do the analysis
that's very themselves um we had several
questions
regarding uh data science and ai and
logistics procurement and
fashion and i just wanted to make one
point about a company the spanish
company zara
which transformed itself
and became a global fashion powerhouse
through the use of data science and
logistics
being able to predict um
trends by analyzing its store sales
um and looking for what was hot
and then shifting production to that and
being able to deliver
through their logistics pipeline quickly
and
that's an example of how these things
converge between
you know functional areas and
industry areas so
yeah and i think we had i think the last
question we're going to
ask uh several people wanted to know
what type of hardware setup they would
need to own personally in order to study
data science and and machine learning
yeah so i think on one hand you you can
buy a hardware yourself but on the other
hand you can
have it all available in the cloud
and the exact setup really depends on
what what you want to do so for example
nvidia just came on the market with jets
jetson i was mentioned this already
in the beginning where you can have we
can build your own
computer vision application or or tool
uh with a device from just fifty dollars
um but
if if you um want to to analyze
um petabytes of data yeah then
you need totally different server
capability then um if you want to do
such a computer vision
application which you can do on a 50
nvidia type type of of tool so
it's hard to say oh this is what you
need but i think
um there's two ways to go and buy all
the hardware yourself
or say okay what um hardware is
available in the cloud and what can uh
can i use
and i'm quite um
in favor of doing the last part so the
more you can
use your cloud
type of environments that the the easier
it
makes it for you and the better you can
scale as you need the compute power so
um all the different cloud platforms
basically support this
and you can move from there whether
you're working on azure or google cloud
or
aws or oracle or ibm
they all facilitate the different
workloads different
tools the different processing power
all on demand and the only thing what
you need is an internet connection
and i would mention also that the the
education
certification programs that simply learn
offers
include virtual environments for doing
all the labs and
and projects so that
you don't need to invest in
[Music]
heavy-duty computing power on your own
um so thank you ronald this has been a
fantastic webinar i
think we have a few technical issues
with uh
webex not transmitting the first few
slides which i apologize for we will be
sending out a recording of the webinar
to the attendees um and hopefully those
problems will be resolved but i do want
to thank you for sharing
uh your knowledge and going in depth
into
these questions i hope that it's been
very helpful to the attendees
in making some uh
plans for developing their career and
exploring both data science and
aiml are you welcome
it was a pleasure um go ahead
and i'd like to show people how to get
in touch with you
let me so either on linkedin on twitter
if you
google my name um i'm on six different
social platforms so you can follow me on
different platforms um
which makes it easy i'm easy to reach
and i publish a lot of content in this
domain so
i'm happy to if you follow me
great and also follow
temple learn but we would like to
mention the next webinar coming up which
is on the subject of digital marketing
and that will be one week from
today on thursday november 5th
same time uh with that expert brad
guerres who is the co-founder of ad
alice's and also a ppc chair at simply
learn
you're talking about the 20 things you
need to know now about ppc
and so look forward to seeing you at
that webinar if
uh digital marketing is an area of
interest and if it's not but you know
people who are
interested in that please feel free to
tell them about the webinar and invite
them
and want to thank you all for being here
we want to thank
ronald again for
his expertise in this presentation
and we will um
go ahead ronald to the next
yep
these are ways you can keep in touch
with simply learn through facebook
twitter
and linkedin and
please feel free to reach out to us i
know that we couldn't answer everybody's
questions today
there's just so many of them but we will
try to follow up with information
about this webinar with a recording of
the webinar
and we look forward to seeing you at
future webinars with simply learn
so that concludes today's presentation
and again
thank you all thank you
you